[Musik]
insbesondere der auf der lauer liegen
inzwischen wieder viel abläuft
schon spannend wie ein krimi herzlich
willkommen beim aufklärungs und
artilleriebataillon vier hier in der
liechtenstein kaserne in ein steig ich
bin mir sicher wir werden hat einen
extrem spannenden tag haben das einzige
was mir jetzt noch fehlt habe ich auch
nicht
[Musik]
wir sagen herzlich willkommen bei uns
überhaupt keine partei und vier belebten
gassen in einem unserer beiden standorte
zweitens dass bei uns bist danke dass
ihr da bin ich es wird dort das wird
sterben
es wird interessant und es los geht
damit löst man in wien jedes packt das
problem oder überall sonst deutlichkeit
was ist es das die panzerhaubitze m109
affen ist das haupt waffensystem der
österreicher artillerie kaliber 155 mm
wir verschließen leuchten nebelgranaten
und zwei sprenggranaten bis auf eine
entfernung von über 25 kilometer
den begriff artillerie kennt man ja aber
was für sap ist die weitreichende feuer
unterstützung für die tanzgruppe das
heißt wir schießen aus der tiefe für die
drucker die von sinn für die infanterie
die ganze quartiere für den konstanzer
und aufgeklärt werden
ja aber die aufklärung versteht das
gegenteil fähigkeiten das ist die
gleiche spiel aufklärung die sie bereits
kennen gelernt hat die hohe schule nach
so einem boden namen find das heißt aber
auch sehr viel technischen einsatz von
technischen beobachtungs mitteln von
drohnen
das heißt aber auch gesprächs aufklärung
spricht mit leuten reden informationen
abnehmen
diese aufklärung regionales
zusammengefassten das ergibt dann ein
lagebild des lagebildes beschluss des
kontaktes gesamtes bild zu haben
[Musik]
der sichere arbeitsplatz hat definitiv
das ist mein arbeitsplatz in der
50-jährigen und das ist die
leitzentralen die führungselite des
bataillons gemeindezentrum das ist es
nun aber auch beweglich und schwer
gemacht sagt ja wir können da auch
gepanzerten fahrzeug vor
da läuft zusammen die informationsbedarf
hier und da fallen auch die
entscheidungen wurden die chancen jetzt
wo immer mit armin veh man dass wir sehr
stark wir haben rund 300 berufssoldaten
bei uns im material männer und frauen
die bei uns wir sehen unsere
hauptaufgabe ist auf die erwartete gerät
und das wissen die augen dabei gerade
riesen wir damals behandelt werden
ich hoffe dass wir raus kommen geredet
wird sagte zu mir also für auflage gilt
viel sie nicht gesehen werden gezüchtet
wie stellen sie stellen
beobachtungsstelle sondern sie nicht
gesehen wird
aber wieso
[Musik]
die bitte der feind hat wir wollen
erstmal nummer also war das war nicht so
gut
das ist kein freier aufgabe sich dem
gelände so perfekt zu verstecken
das scherzt wenn beeindruckt seine texte
wir kommen jetzt einen scharfen schuss
das erste was man schließen dass ein
leben geraten wir haben hier mit einer
mechanischen zünder müssen zuerst ein
bier
das ist nichts was mit dem flugzeug
läuft noch unter druck das camp tieren
vom lateinischen tempus daherkommt und
dazu nutzen wir dieses dem gerät 419
rutscht noch ein komplett raus
ja ja die heute hier erpresst in der
musik macht richtig ja immer nah er
damit das gesetz feuerwehr und sogar
hätte wort geworden ja ich habe es
gehört
die arbeit sehr kleine einweisung
bekommen aber das ist ein job für
normalerweise gelernt wird
ich weiß zumindest aber jetzt genug um
es einmal alleine zu versuchen
wirklich ich habe die leine haft ja
genau und straft
feuer frei christologie so richtig
richtig fest
mama papa oder wie man halo jetzt weiß
ich zwar wieder sieht man auf der
richtigen seite der abwehr steht nämlich
davos zu wird aber natürlich schaue ich
mir auch an wie das ist dort wohin
geschossen wird also hier wäre zum
beispiel dass hinterher
dieses wunderschöne eigenheim bastler
hat für ein bis zwei personen
jetzt ist kein rennen und ich gehe auch
durch entdeckung wenn das ist das ziel
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt genau da wo sie hin
schießen hundert meter von uns entfernt
ist die hütte gleich sprenger werden
das hier ist panzerglas haben sie mir
versichert
[Musik]
butschek schenkt
schauen wir mal was das angerichtet hat
ja gleich daneben war vorher noch aus
jetzt ist hier halt ein großes loch man
muss sich vorstellen
wir schießen das über acht kilometer
entfernung eine unglaubliche präzision
trotzdem so beeindruckt über sie ist
einmal froh dass dieser übung ist weiß
er auch dass man keine frage
vielleicht verlegte ohren
und wahrscheinlich auch biografien der
hose haben und das war es ja sehr weit
sind also ich hab einen wieder einmal
wahnsinnig tollen tag beim bundesheer
verbracht dafür möchte ich danken das
kann ich jemanden wie danke dir dass du
hast du hast was gesehen
du hast uns aufgeklärt dass ich alles
geschossen was da auf uns und was bei
uns besonders bei der artillerie und
schutzpatron ist die heilige barbara
aber uns aber gerne heilige barbara für
dich mit soli beschützen und die küche
bringen
die nämlich sehr sehr gern vielen vielen
dank und alles gute die auch einen
versuch starten dazu
[Musik]
das wollte immer schon haben danke